what's your name
what is your name your name my name baby
your name is baby
BB BB yes and you my name is Mark nice
to meet you baby baby I love your outfit
yeah thank you very much you look great
um I'm a photographer huh I am a
photographer yeah I would love to take
your photograph you're beautiful oh well
thank you very much I will pay you $20
for what how many B chips just my studio
is here on 7th Street you know you know
Rebecca how much how much 40
I'll bring you back baby where are you
from I am from Mexico Mexico a city in
Mexico Guadalajara and how long have you
do the United States about 15 years 15
years
so you're out there on the street it's
early in the morning what what time did
you get here what time excuse me what
good time 4:00 in the morning 3:00 in
the morning mostly for to say 4:00 to
7:00 a.m. but Friday Saturday Sunday
only weakens the only weekend well I
love what you're wearing tonight
your beautiful boots you're very stylish
I think you're the best-dressed girl out
there on the streets now so you're a
woman now beautiful woman thank you
when did he become a woman thank you
10 years ago 10 G 7 and you have
beautiful breasts thank you
and do you have everything taken care
for now yes I hoped
well I see so some of the girls have had
more surgery than others yes yes and the
men that you pick up they like that you
have everything but suppose something
for everybody
forbidden weapons asked me for something
different
okay what - okay yeah where do you go
with the menu go to the car or you go to
your apartment - where you go you should
be my god they discard sometimes in my
apartment
where's your apartment by lievable what
rocks from pretty far away funny looks
from oh you're very close yes nobody
close that makes it easy
[Music]
and do your parents how do your parents
feel about this do they know that you're
a woman they know about
for now they didn't all what I am tall
enough personnel yeah yeah I don't
expect them to know that but but just
when you go home for visits to
Guadalajara cuando la Jara you're a
dress like a woman yes under like I
wanna wear you know avoid pants over
that yeah something just in there okay
yeah that's good
[Music]
so what advice would you give somebody
who's looking to get into this line of
work that girl a young girl who wants to
do this any advice if you feel there you
are if you da new generations want to
you know my advice is for now it's okay
because the police is a little they let
you go
yes before the 90s victory in jail a
uniform mouths okay
the police field how many times have you
been in jail how about three times three
times that's not bad
tennis for one night two nights yeah
only four hours so four hours cuz you're
hours my friend Penta bail bail it again
good for you so look at you yeah bet
your your beautiful boots you've got a
goal it's a goal from a
Jack oh my gosh look at those that's it
beautiful when did you have these done
these totems
that's a hormone you're kidding me no
sir they're hormones the other do yes
yeah yeah plastic surgery no no no in
the men like your breasts at first yeah
and when you you have sex with the men
what kind of stuff do they end up
warhead they like David well they they
probably want whatever they can get
right uh-huh
what kind of men do you pick up black
men white men Hispanic Chinese
everything everything very everything
because the Moses are Hispanic mostly
it's not tell me a crazy story Oh crazy
story with a man they like - okay I want
to I want to
[Music]
hey I want to pull your dress
they want to put your threads mine he
wants to wear your clothes yes wow so he
wants to be a woman today take me a
picture
take my picture with you oh he was a
picture taken yes but in that case I go
to my place yes what's the most you made
in one night how about 4 5 4 5 mm but
regular is 250 to fail to 250 yeah
mm-hmm thank you you're lovely
thank you so much okay
[Music]